[Musik]
meine damen und herren ich bin hauptmann
dominique risch ich bin der
verantwortliche für die dynamische
vorführung heute am nationalfeiertag in
graz präsentieren ihnen heute den
angriff auf einen konvoi des
österreichischen bundesheers kurz darauf
erst etwa nur dann auf einen so
genannten zweiten satz auf sofort
reagiert der zugkommandant und lässt die
besatzung absitzen um einen
gegenmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
nach dem angriff der ersten gruppe über
recht und dem einsatz des
maschinengewehrs mit dem leider ein
eigener mann aus fällt das heißt eine
vermummung leidet setzt die zweite
gruppe über links an und wird die
feindlichen kräfte auf der kreuzung
danach wird sofort eine sahen versorgung
durchgeführt und sowohl der feindliche
als auch der eigene verwundete geborgen
und erstversorgt
[Musik]
[Applaus]